shifting center question so far all of
those simple have animation when you're
looking at right it has a center of
motion at the origin they know we've
dealt with questions where it's not but
I have addressed it formally so let's
come back to our first idea of the
displacement of some kind of particle
object if it's going to exhibit a simple
humming motion it must be a wave
function right so let's take this as
just a general example okay obviously I
could have chosen cosine but what I'm
gonna demonstrate is gonna work exactly
the same anyway there's an amplitude
that's where your period comes from
there's your face okay now let's just
rehearse rehearse the result for X
double dot okay
just do it by differentiation so if we
differentiate it was to get velocity
okay
it's chainable so that in comes out at
the front side turns into cosine and
what's inside the trig function stays
the same differentiate again and you
will see the familiar result the
difference the present we're familiar
with again because it comes out the
front another one so that's a squared
right
cosine turns into negative sign some
slack
- Simon off the front
that's alcohol okay so you can see now
if I put this aid over here it's a bit
of a weed spot to put it you can see
that it's just X right and there's my -
and square so there's my difference in
the equator happy okay now if I want to
reposition the centre of motion up or
down somewhere else
okay if you come back to this
displacement equation right you can take
the same old wave function to sound fun
right and to just change where it is in
terms of position all I do is add or
subtract a constant right so let's call
that constant X naught what that's gonna
do is in this case I'm moving up x9
units so excellent negative I'm going
down okay all left left all right
yep all right now let's just keep this
in mind and go through the same process
right so when you get a X dot okay
differentiating because it's just a
cluster you vanishes so track I'm gonna
get the same results that I got on the
left-hand side right because it's almost
identical so I'm still gonna get am
cause I'm still gonna get - a.m. squared
okay so you can see that I can't pull
this minus N squared X right because N
squared X would be cluding this cluster
right so I need to really get a little
bit so that I get a new differential
equation okay now what's the cave see
that I might actually let's put the N
squared out up front this I can see I'm
substituting for that
okay I have something a little bit
different here right so what am I going
to do to enable me to sub into this
equation
well if I rearrange this a little bit
right get my age sine NT plus alpha on
its own okay so that I can sub it into
here that a sign into plus alpha all I
have to do is kick the X naught to the
other side which sort of shouldn't
surprise us because when you've got X
minus something that's how we normally
do a shift of like a parabola x squared
- x - 2 squared or something like that
okay so therefore this is going to be
this a sine NT plus alpha we will sub in
for this whole thing getting the whole
right-hand side so I'm going to get this
so there's a new differential equation
it's still exhibits simple harmonic
motion because it's still a wave
function right but you can see the
equations just ever so slightly
different so either of these if you show
them that's enough to principle harmonic
motion let's have a look at example